good morning guys just got back to the
states not too long ago and i just got a
phone call that's music to my ears i've
been oh my
look how big those tires are what the
dude are those monster truck tires that
thing's bigger than a semi truck
holy
well anyways
i got 35s on my truck
not too long ago thinking was going to
be perfect
because back in the day when i had
lifted trucks um you put 35s on
full-size trucks 33s on compact trucks
like tacomas and stuff
and it looked clean it was perfect it
wasn't like too big and it looked just
right so when i got
my silverado i was like you know i'm
gonna put 35s on there
forgetting that trucks have been getting
bigger and bigger and bigger every
single year like the compact truck of
today like a tacoma is bigger than a
silverado of like the 90s you know
not that i was driving trucks in the 90s
but that's when i first really got into
cars and so my silverado
kind of makes the 35s look tiny
like it looks clean and dope but it does
look a little bit underwhelming
like it doesn't like the shoes don't fit
the person you know what i mean like it
looks like this dude's like 6'3 and he
got like size 7 shoes on so it feels
weird so shout outs to larry at yokohama
for tracking down my tires i was like
you know what i'm gonna go one size up
hook me up with some 37s
but off-roading is so huge right now and
you got a bunch of super trucks now you
got the raptor the trx everybody want
the new tundra just came out everybody
wants 37s so it's so hard to track them
down and after about almost six months
of waiting they finally tracked bounce
them
and they're the new models the xas which
is in between like an extreme off-road
one and also everyday driver one which
is gonna be perfect for me because i
drive my truck as a daily driver but
that is a god
all over the place um
but i also do some light off-roading so
that's gonna be really cool and the
reason why that's cool is you might be
asking why not just go with an extreme
off-road one it's because when you gotta
go with the extreme off-road one they're
hella knobby meaning they get like a ton
of grip like that so it looks aggressive
it looks freaking dope but when you're
on the freeway it's allowed to go
you'll hear that doesn't get good gas
mileage and it actually doesn't grip the
ground that good when it's raining on
just flat roads because if the road is
flat if you think about it there's not
that much contact service uh
service surface
you know on the flip side
when you got something that's really
good for the road
where has a lot of contact surface that
when you're going into a place where
there's tons of rocks
flies are going crazy on me when you go
to a place with a ton of rocks it
doesn't grip it that good and you want
then is when you want something to
knobby so they got the new
um yokohama xt's or xa's i gotta double
check the xyzbfgd
check them out uh shout out to yokohama
for lokinet la locating them
these flies or mosquitoes whatever they
are on me they're causing me to starter
and i'm gonna go get my tires because
this is going crazy bones
all right guys i got the actual name of
these tires
they're gonna be 37 by 12 and a half my
rims are 17 and they are the geo x dash
ats x meaning extreme a meaning all
terrain
got four of these bad boys
so if you guys like what you see after i
put them on my truck
um go ahead and check them out they're
yokohama's brand new line and i've heard
really good things about them from a
combination of getting good gas mileage
um lasting a long time
grippy off-road and very quiet so i'm
really happy and excited to test them
out
all right guys got the tires loaded
bam right here i got my 37s geox ats
these are 37s and these are 35s once i
get to the shop i'll put them next to
each other and although
it might only seem like it's two inches
bigger we all know two inches go a long
way now i'm just kidding um
when it comes to the stance of a vehicle
whether it's like a porsche like a
sports car or a lifted car those inch or
two makes a huge difference that's why
there's a huge difference when it comes
to like putting 19s on your car or 20
inch rims or even 21s so i'll put them
on the side and then once you get all
four of them on and it raises the car
like just an inch or two it just gives
it that extra
so i'm really really excited
and uh
i couldn't find a better way to put it
on also i actually i have like ratchets
and stuff and straps inside my car but
i'm just so excited i don't want to
waste too much time so i just put this
cheap little bungee cord
and i'm gonna just try to drive safe
because it's not too far away and
hopefully they don't fall out because if
they fall out i'm asked out
because it took six months to find these
bad boys so
shout outs to yokohama
at the shop now and here is my original
tire
which is already way bigger than the
stock
that is the 37.
i roll this up next to it
you can clearly tell
it's way bigger especially if i cover it
up right
and look how much it closes up that
wheel cap
so this is what it looks like without
right now when you have something just a
little bit beefier
it just
fell backwards i was walking back i
didn't see this car holy [ __ ] i'm having
the clumsiest day ever
i'm literally getting lit up by
mosquitoes
and i don't even see the curb but
anyways
back to this you'll see when you zoom
out
it would focus
i had to turn the camera back on and off
because it wasn't focusing but if you
would focus
when you zoom out that's when there's
that subtle difference
and that little inch just raises the
truck just a little bit more
you see that see how it just just a
little bit
and when you're trying to fix up a car
it's all about the details as they say
so i'm excited to put this on and also
shout outs to my other sponsor
diamondback covers getting your cover
put on here with all kinds of
accessories so that way uh when i make
these long distance road trips right now
the only storage i have is in my deck
system which is sick
but when i'm traveling with people um i
can't use the back of my truck
like i do still store things in the back
of my truck
like in there like i got gym bags
uh gifts for people and stuff like that
so
if i'm gonna make more long distance
road trips i need more storage space
more secure space like if i need to stop
by to get food i can't be having stuff
open in the back of the truck so i love
trucks they're so versatile and carry
[ __ ] all the time
the only downside is if you don't have a
secure storage
you can't just lay things out so
diamondback covers sick covers this
whole thing so that gives me the ability
to store all kinds of stuff in between
here and it lifts up
and it uninstalls in minutes
if i need my truck bed again for
something like this i'm good to go
and uh the diamondback cover is also
really strong with the stand on it if i
want to load stuff on top like a flatbed
i can treat it like a flatbed which is
sick so i think by the time i add that
on the tires on
i think this project is done
besides of course the big old dent that
joe put in the side of my truck which i
still got to get that fixed
once i get that fixed
this bad boy
is finally
finished all right just dropped off the
truck i'm a happy camper can't wait to
see what my finished truck looks like
i looked up
a starbucks somewhere close where i
could get some work done and it says
it's about a half mile away which is not
bad at all considering i need to get ten
thousand steps in
because as you guys know
i'm trying to lose weight for the summer
and if you guys follow the barter
brigade channel me and geo are in direct
competition we're both running the
barbell brigade get lean program and i
have to get 10 000 steps in
and i only have 1200 steps
right now
and since today is not a training day
my steps are way lower
like when i'm training because i'm
moving around and stuff like that i
think i automatically get about three to
four thousand steps in
with all the stretching the warming up
and my dynamic warm-ups assault bike
so
i only have to make up like six thousand
uh steps after that
but on days i'm not training
i'm not doing all that i literally drove
for an hour to get here so i'm just
stationary you know so it's about
the amount of physical activity that you
do too
like if you notice a lot of mailmen
are just naturally lean
because of the activity that they're
doing
so your daily activity
is actually
almost more important
than your actual training your training
is trying to change your physique trying
to put on muscle trying to get strong
but if you want to keep your calories
low you want to increase your physical
activity throughout the day which is why
many coaches would recommend to get 8
000
8 000 steps in for me i'm on a hard cut
i want to beat geo so i'm trying to get
10 000.
so just by me walking down the street so
far i add another 200 to it so i see the
starbucks right there so i'll be working
right
over wait what right
right over there
and hopefully
no more clumsy [ __ ]
happens to me today man no mosquitoes
i don't want to be tripping
i definitely don't want nobody coming
over spilling hot coffee on my computer
or anything like that
i see a red light
i'ma stop right here
with my luck today nothing's going good
got a bunch of work done pretty happy
about that we're working on a bunch of
sick new designs for barbell brigade
especially in the oversized tee like the
one that i'm wearing right now this is
the home tee by the time this video
comes out
not only would the home tea have
launched it probably would have sold out
because the reception on even our sneak
peeks have been insane so a lot of
people really like um our oversized tee
the fitment the colors
and it's just what's in right now you
know so we're really excited to continue
that with the rest of this year bring
back some more like
bb loud and proud heavy graphics
especially that's what people like to
rock in the gym
is it raining
dude
today's nuts dude not only am i clumsy
the weather's clumsy it's sunny look at
the ground
there's water droplets
it's sunny and rainy what is this
hawaii this is crazy bounds
dude i'm so glad nothing clumsy uh
happened in starbucks because with my
track record this morning i was so
scared so when i was sitting there i was
like i'm moving i bought a black coffee
i found a table in my corner i don't
want to bump it to nobody or nothing i'm
just going to sit right there have my
laptop open
and my phone on the side occupy the
whole table by myself and
a good thing
everything went smoothly
i actually didn't even get a phone call
yet that my car's done
i was just starting to get hungry and it
was a good natural um
little break in my work so i was like
you know what let me get a little more
steps in
walk over there see what's up
i am on a hardcore diet so i can't be
just like much not anything you know so
i'll go see how much more time i have
left
if i got more than an hour
i'm gonna go try to find some food
their shop truck is so nice look at that
they got 37s too so it's big and beefy
but they also got like the crazy uh long
travel kit in the front look at that
thing it's like a crazy piece of
machinery i don't even know what the
hell it is
it looks freaking rad
so they told me i still got about
another
hour
so i'm like looking for food the
problemo is
there's this place right here called
chilito's mexican grill
right there and oh my god it looks good
so i don't have to go anywhere far
it's right here
but also not conducive to my diet
there's also a
subway down the street
another mexican place with four and a
half stars called green taco
damn play a playa
oh my god do me like this
uh
i was hoping there's like some hot food
the subway it's like sandwiches right
it's not technically hot food i would
like to get
even if i go like a marine calendars get
like a chicken breast that's pretty good
oh soul kitchen soul food
look at that dude so oh my gear
but you know they put all that extra
seasoning in there too probably got like
butter
on their
chicken
you know what i'ma just be good i'm
gonna go to subway
dude
i'm literally
having the weirdest day in the world so
first of all i got my sandwich to go
because there was a homeless guy taking
a shower a shower a shower where the
soda fountains were you know how you
could get water from there this dude was
getting water
and then he's like splashing all over
himself
and the two workers there are these like
two shy girls so i feel bad for them
they probably feel threatened so they
don't want to say anything
you know they're just watching them like
get all these ice cubes out like filling
up his own container using that water to
take a shower and he doesn't look like
safe to be around you know like he looks
pretty nuts
and then
i go and try to pay
and their card machine is not working i
pay with two different cards they both
don't work they reboot it reset it still
doesn't work
and the lady was like you know what just
take the sandwich for free i'm like what
are you serious i mean that's so nice of
you he goes yeah i can't even take
payment and they already made it so i'm
like dude that's super cool of you guys
because um i actually got double protein
too so i'm trying to like stay on a diet
and make sure i hit my protein
requirement so
i got hooked up
not gonna eat in the restaurant
uh now i'm gonna try to find like a
little nice area
i was gonna sit on like a bench
but there's a lot of different like
characters around here
see there's that dude over there
lots of like random
characters all over the place
so i don't know if it's the smartest
move for me
to be like put in a vulnerable spot you
know
so the best place that i could find to
eat is back in the shop
where it's nice and safe i got ac
no crazy characters there was like at
least six of them this is what i got it
doesn't look that appetizing but i'm
making the best of what i got got a
italian bread got double roast beef
olives
lettuce spinach tomatoes banana peppers
um i got the roast beef because it has
like a four almost five to one protein
of fat ratio
so that's what you're looking for so i
get like maybe i think i might almost
get 100 grams of protein out of this
because i uh doubled the protein and
then i think i might have four or maybe
24 grams of fat which is not bad at all
considering i'm getting 100 grams of
protein
and i only got mustard because any other
dressing is gonna have fat in it so it's
gonna throw me off but i'm really proud
of myself i'm sticking to this
so my truck is done and it came out
pretty sick man look at that
big old
beefy
37 inch tires definitely fit way better
got a little bit of a sag in the back
because i got my old tires up there
but i got my diamond back cover shout
out to diamondback for hooking me up
with this and also my front runner rack
kit
so i still gotta find a place for those
bad boys but
it looks pretty sick everything tucks in
real nice
looks super good once i remove all four
of those tires it won't sag as much
because i also have deeper leaf springs
in the back which is like a softer
spring so it feels good but the whole
like black and white look
looks really
freaking
awesome
now he's got to get
that little thing fixed
but other than that super happy
all right just got to the jk office i
figured this would be a cool spot to
store the tires i did already put the
tires on offer up and i put it up for
super cheap i think each one of my 35s
can go for anywhere between three to
four hundred bucks
they're lightly used
so that's like what like 1200 to 1600
i'm putting it on offer up for 800. so
hopefully someone comes and grabs them
because i don't want to have to deal
with it once i'm in vegas but once i
took it off oh man the truck looks tough
love the big old tires i can't wait to
get some of that like uh
armor all on it because right now it
looks a little bit faded but once it
gets that armor on there's a little bit
beefy
this truck is looking pretty tough
if you ask me
look at that
damn
i'm pretty much done i was on the fence
on if i should wrap it or not
and
i didn't want to i like the stormtrooper
look the black and white but now looking
at all the stuff on it the white kind of
looks boring you know
there's all this cool like texture on
the rack
and then and on the uh bed cover that
i'm like dang i think it needs a little
something something
so i might have to put a little
something something on it
you know my style
so i got the uh
tires just stacked up
at the jk office just like this
35s
see lightly used still got some of the
like
on it
these things are freaking huge
what's gonna suck is um
that room is probably gonna smell tiring
but hopefully i get rid of it in three
days
now i gotta go get a haircut
dude steve you know every time i'm back
in the 66 i always have to get my
haircut here i know every time every
time every time you come back you always
support band yeah
yeah you guys got to stay open forever
we will we tried you know me and anthony
have a dream that if we make it really
big we're going to buy it from you and
then keep it alive
yeah yeah yeah that's the dream that's
right that's our dream
yeah one of the worst dancers in the
world that'd be cool hey bud we're gonna
be here for another 10 years okay good
now because vince is like uh it's like a
66 staple you know we were working here
like our hand is shaking then
you can't be cutting hair or shake your
head
no no no no no no
glasses is the start i mean oh no
they've never seen me with glasses oh
that's true but my my hair always looks
good even you need glasses yeah oh no i
mean i can cut your hair blindfolded oh
really you know how my head is yep yep
that's true
every time i'm in town gotta stop by vin
hair salon
a staple in the 626
community fun fact
so these guys been around here for a few
decades now
and i asked them like because you know
back in the 90s and early 2000s the
asian gangs here were going crazy that
was the stuff you saw like the armani
pool hall shooting
like you go
to high school and everyone is dressed
like all flamed out and red or all blue
or all black or all gray or whatever and
there's like just straight up like
like
everyone was like cholo style right and
i'm like man
if everyone gets their haircut at the
same place
how did your shop not get
shot up
and he was saying that people respected
the barber so much because all gangsters
got to look good still
that if someone rolled in and saw
someone getting a haircut they would
respect it and just go all right it'll
just bounce out because of that like
asian boys watching cool boys black
dragon all those gangs um
no one ever like took each other out
here and they all respected it
i'm like that's freaking dope and i come
here because a lot of places got clean
fades right
but um
no one really has the experience to
shape the head and that's really
important so my hair my head goes like
this and there's like a little big dent
right here
and they always do a good job of making
it fade like this so that when i gel my
hair
i have a nice my my whole shape is done
well and that's to me
like the telltale sign of if someone is
super sick and experienced
or they just learn how to fade because
uh fading i think is easy shaping the
whole head is the hard part
so this is a side of me that you guys
probably
never see
it is 6 55 and the reason why i'm
stopping by the jk office
is today is a launch day for us for
barber game
and so when it's launch day as the tires
again um when it's launch day
i have to make sure that
everything
is in working order so for example
um before
seven because everyone is camping out at
seven right everyone wants to make sure
they get what they want
and so they're probably waiting already
um i got to make sure that like my ig
launch posts go out
my
uh the barbell brigade ig launch posts
go out the email goes out the youtube
video that's promoting the campaign goes
out i gotta make sure that all the links
work
because the last thing you want is like
um
you know the links are a broken link
people can't get what they want and then
also making sure the server doesn't
crash and the website's in working order
and that's also communicating to the
shipping so it's just the whole
enchilada it's like making sure you
almost feel like you're a pilot
and i got to stop talking about 30
seconds but you got to feel like you're
a pilot because you're you're managing
like a cockpit with all these dashboard
and all these moving parts and you're
like staying tuned to the comments to
see if there's any slight signs of
anything going haywire then you could
jump on it asap and communicate with
everyone else in the team that's
involved so that's about to go uh our
launch about to go live real soon so uh
i'm gonna be here real quick using the
internet making sure that everything is
smooth
oh my goodness look what i'm coming home
to
animals
these guys are straight up animals
[Applause]
what do you guys want from me
what do you want to beat me up for
because we want your money my money yo
right
yeah
give me money come here whoa come here
are you guys vampires yeah yeah are you
a vampire
i think i need to go somewhere else
this is too dangerous
no i'm gonna go somewhere this is scary
what do you got over there dude
oh yeah cult yeah look one two three
four seven
four what did i see five but look one
two three four five five one more
wait a little kettle game
three four five hey good job
one two three
is that your favorite drink yeah i love
it too papa grew up on it that means
that drink is like almost 30 years old
because papa was drinking it since he
was a baby
and that's crazy bombs
yeah and i growed up and now you like it
too that's cutie pie
i was drinking at your age isn't that
crazy bones
oh you can't any chinchilla grown up
yeah
i would i'll eat more
i put that out
so we're at the grocery store because we
need to stick to our diet so
we got to get a lot of stuff because
everything about diet is sticking to
preparation right like being prepared
before we're hungry so i found some
really good finds this bad boy right
here vegetable and chicken dumplings
look at this
six grams of protein only 1.5 grams of
fat that's an insanely good ratio
also i love me some red meat got some
964 which is also really good ratio 23
grams of protein only 4.5 grams of fat
and then i found these bad boys they're
starting to do the airfryer freezing
ones look at this
16 grams of protein guess how many grams
of fat
four yup really four to one ratio and
then you know me and my little
snackaroos these guys are only 40
calories for one stick can you believe
there's only 40 times for one stick you
don't i'm taking it away
hey what so run run are you kidding me
and of course this guy gets a lot of
good snacks the good stuff right here oh
my goodness
that's some fat-free cooking spray cutie
froot loops
mama got some greek yogurt
and i uh
don't stop by my taco shop anymore which
i love stocking stopping by grab a
couple of these sometimes um
i just need a couple carbs down with
these and i'm a happy camper
hey what are you doing dude don't be
touching other people's peaches
see this big old pot right here i had a
big yummy dinner
i ate 20 dumplings no so good but that's
not what i'm worried about during a diet
they're on a diet i'm worried about
temptation so when i'm in control i'm
not tempted
one i'm at jk news
and there's yummy snacks everywhere and
people bringing them food and bun man
vietnamese coffee that's what i'm
tempted which is why i made two of these
guys egg whites and ham egg whites and
ham
someone be prepared tomorrow so as soon
as i see someone bust out something
yummy i'm gonna start scarfing this down
and then pretend like i'm uh eating what
they're eating i know it's so sad but
one day i will be sexy i promise
thank you guys for following me on such
a cool day i'll see you guys
there's nothing i've met for you to hear
hey that's my boobie
goodnight
smells weird huh mama smells so funny
you taste stinky